President Trump has been critical of
calls for his son Don Jr to testify
again on Capitol Hill here's what he
told reporters on the South Lawn today
my son spent I guess over 20 hours
testifying about something that Muller
said was a hundred percent okay and now
they want him to testify again I don't
know why I have no idea why but it seems
very unfair to me
there was a subpoena and now there's a
change of plans
what are you hearing there there is
we've we've heard we understand that the
Senate Intelligence Committee and Donald
Trump jr. have come to an accommodation
that he will come back for more
testimony sometime in June Donald Trump
jr. had a letter ready to go to send to
the Senate Intelligence Committee saying
that he was not going to come up and
that enough was enough he's not going to
go through this again basically daring
them to hold him in contempt at the
eleventh hour though the committee said
we don't want to do this can we work
this out and so for the for the first
time in months the committee agreed to
what Donald Trump jr. had been asking
for and that is a return engagement
limited in time and scope one to two
hours with limited follow-up they cite
all kinds of things in this letter
including his 25 hours of testimony the
fact that his testimony before the
Senate Intelligence Committee had been
cited in the mullah report and the fact
that they wanted to compare his answers
to those of a convicted liar Michael
Cohen right okay John thank you